so tripe is the inner lining of the
stomach tripe is a cow's third penis
sick when the weather gets cold one of
my favorite things to do is to hit up a
hotpot spot to warm up around a bubbling
cauldron of soup so when I heard that
there was a curry hotpot at Hometowne
hotpot and barbecue on Grand Street I
had to check it out today we're feasting
Malaysian style with Ronny Chang and
actor comedian and Daily Show
correspondent who hit the big time with
his role in the movie event of the year
crazy rich Asians let's see what this
curry shop hotpot is all about I'm
actually not quite familiar with
Malaysian cuisine but there is a heavy
Indian influence in there how could you
describe what Malaysian cuisine is for
someone who doesn't know Malaysian
cuisine is probably in my opinion in my
humble opinion the best cuisine in the
world Malaysia is like a melting pot in
Asia so you have Chinese people Indian
people Malay people white people lots of
different cultures coming in and they
kind of mixed up their cuisine in the
same way a literal melting pot of food
so it creates a very unique flavor which
I haven't been able to find outside
Malaysia and I pry but in lieu of being
in Malaysia
let's try whatever they have here you
brought up the point of the melting pot
literal and figurative idea yeah
Malaysia is literally a melting pot is
hot as [ __ ] New Yorkers might be
familiar with Chinese or Szechuan hotpot
but how big of a deal is hotpot in
Malaysian cooking I'm very surprised to
hear that New Yorkers eat hotpot
like gold more Chinese hot pot I thought
New York is just eat you know stupid
[ __ ] off the street like hot dogs
and maybe maybe in Malaysia we use like
more Malaysian ingredients maybe the
flavor of the broth like in Malaysia
they might use rundown in the broth but
I mean the idea is the same right you
put flavor into soup when you boil the
thing and you eat everything you can
until you vomit I mean that's I think
there's almost difference between
Malaysian and Chinese hoplite at all
before we get to the hot pot we're gonna
try a couple other things on the menu
we're gonna have some barbecue are you
really won't eat anything you point from
you right now how about this place I'll
eat that right now
there we go before we get to the hot pot
we're gonna try some of hometowns
barbecue options ordered all-you-can-eat
and grilled right at your tables today
we're going to be cooking up pieces of
steak ribs pork belly
steak with satay sauce and hometown's
curry chicken breast strips
all right look at all this food yeah
that's one thing I love about going for
Asian barbecue it's like when people
think of Asian food maybe they get a bit
squeamish because I think it's very
exotic and they don't know whether
they'll have the taste for it but it's
just barbecue meat everyone can get
behind barbecue me if you don't like
this and what the [ __ ] do you eat it's
really the only downside to Asian
barbecue is that you come out smelling
like a barbecue now how long do we let
it um this is where the art comes in
just have to fuel it it's no answer it's
not equation the meat is sliced so thin
that it cooks very quickly worst case it
gets a little charred but you can't
really overcook it I think with that
you're looking at I can't really make a
mistake I can you quickly for that boy
good thank you you're using Malaysian
sauces this looks like road rundown
right here
rundown is like a Malay curry how
important is curry with Malaysian
cooking interesting you know I love how
this show is about curry because you're
right every culture does curry
differently I think that's even a
variation in how Indian people in
Malaysia doing a courage versus how in
every way ninjas do it when done so
Malay version of the curry Chinese curry
I guess laksa is technically a soupy
curry that you drink come in yeah we
used a lot okay everyone's laughing at
the scissors you're not laughing now are
you look at this how efficient this is
first time we brought this out with with
my friends I don't say what kind of
people they were
say you're white and we brought out
scissors and they laugh they said what
is this
who the hell use the scissors with me
you're not laughing now are you one of
the best ideas ever mmm goes great so on
this set of crazy rich Asians what kind
of food were you eating guys it's crazy
Asians filmed on-location in Malaysia
and Singapore my hometowns every night
we going out
someone from Queens how do I name names
by Aquafina was I got yet chillies in
this mall I'm like we're not living in a
mall
we're hitting the chocolate Dell the one
time yen fish ball noodles the steamed
fish what what do we eat what do we not
we ate everything in the lake of like
two months all right Ronnie we gotta
save room we gotta save the room so
before we eat the hot pot we're gonna
kick it to Mike Chen who's gonna give us
more information
hey Ronnie hey Jasleen it's Mike Chen
saying hi from the road in the
beautifully delicious Vancouver Canada
and we're gonna talk about how about
today one of my most favorite food items
in the world and with hotpot you'll have
a boiling pot of super in front of you
in a ray of vegetables and meats and the
means usually slice very thin because
it's needs to cook in seconds to retain
that fresh meaty flavor and hop out is
dish you can find all across Asia but
different Asian countries would have
their own variations of it for example
the Chinese hot pot which is called agua
typically comes with many types of broth
the most popular being the spicy and
yummy broth and in places like Singapore
and Malaysia the hotpot is known as the
steamboat and there's very similar to
Chinese hot pot maybe a little more
emphasis on seafood and the broth is a
little more full body and this is why
love Malaysian cuisine because it is the
quintessential fusion food it took
influences from China from India from
the native Malay and they came up with
their only unique way of cookie they're
only unique flavors that just out of
this world
for example curry which is an important
part of Malaysian cuisine the Korean
Eliza's herbs seized
yogurt a lot of native ingredients like
coconut milk or tamarind juice to create
his only unique blend of flavors and
speaking of curry I know you guys are
eating curry hotpot today maybe next
time it might me sip your broth at the
end I call it the magic hour you know
like when the Sun sets what a flavor is
just gathering together towards the
bottom that's the greatest soup ever
it's a communal meal have fun have a
great conversation share your food
that's why you go to an all-you-can-eat
hot pop place eat all you want and you
never feel bad because who cares we got
the last dumpling all right guys enjoy
your meal next time again invite me see
ya next up we're gonna be trying
hometown spicy malla hotpot in Chinese
cuisine malla refers to the marriage of
spicy chili peppers but the numbing
sensation brought on by Szechuan
peppercorns in the bras we're gonna be
cooking thin slices of beef chicken
gizzard fried tofu skin tripe and then
lettuce mushrooms and green bean noodles
all right we have everything I'm excited
but I need a little bit of a tutorial on
what to do for the hot pot again this
looks very intimidating it's a big
spread yeah it cooks down everything
shrinks when you cook it all happen is
that the flavors start kind of combining
in the pot I was also like a feature of
hot pot so instead of like trying to
pick out what you like I suggest you mix
all together and give everything a shot
cuz sometimes the combination is greater
than the sum of its parts so what goes
in first typically I would say generally
a smart thing to do would be to put in
the things that take the longest to cook
first all right well let's get to it are
there any Jews and dumps for the hot pot
like what is a rookie mistake proper hot
pot etiquette is you kind of take out
only what you put in so if you put a
mushroom then you can take out mushroom
I'll take out two mushrooms yeah you
only put one in putting stuff into hot
water and cooking it's caveman eating
you don't need to be going on Ramsay you
don't need to be insert celebrity chef
here you don't need to be Emeril live
yeah whoever that is yeah just do what
you want to it's it's very casual now
it's just the treasure hunt portion of
the meal just looking for stuff you put
in five minutes ago maybe you forgot
about no mistakes here just happy
accidents
okay totally Bob Ross look at this I put
that in ten Michigan I didn't remember
that well that's got a spice yeah it's
this each one spice well that's really
good ma means numb lobbies like spicy
hot so that gives you any indication of
what you're gonna taste here it's not
like hot sauce and it's not curry it's
something else yeah so hard to describe
alright so we've tried this hotpot but
we're gonna try the curry hotpot which
I'm super stoked about cuz we've heard
so much about it are you ready yeah
let's do it
now for the main event we're gonna be
trying hometowns curry hotpot the broth
starts with the curry paste fermented
shrimp paste oil chili sauce curry
powder soy sauce human fennel and
tumeric are combined the paste is then
mixed into coconut milk and curry leaves
are added into the broth to go along
with the soup we've ordered slices of
lamb beef tendon balls and pork blood
so now we have the much-awaited curry
hotpot and I'm Emily I think I figured
out the tools and techniques to this so
let me just get us started
sure all right okay start out again I
really yeah it doesn't matter but I
don't want to put that in first so here
we go we're gonna throw in some of these
mushrooms oh I shouldn't use my hands
right [ __ ] here we go
don't use the chops don't use my chops
remember other why I said you can't go
wrong I know you're about to roast me
right now we've had hotpot but this is a
curry hotpot which is a little bit
different I feel like it's more maybe
focused on the broth it's a more diluted
curry so you can cook stuff in it I'm
told that this is like a Panang curry so
Penang is like a city in Malaysia that's
known for having really really good food
and I think what makes Panang curry
Penang curry is they add latch onto it
black China is like a fermented shrimp
paste that's also spicy gives it like a
unique flavor has a more of a creamier
texture to it I like it it's really good
even Penang curry wouldn't necessarily
be like this would be a bit thicker okay
this is like a hotpot version of it
Indians are the third largest ethnic
group in Malaysia obviously we see that
there's connection within the food and
the curry yeah so I mean Malaysia is a
truly multicultural country and a lot of
the food that we take pride in in
Malaysia is actually Indian food thank
God rocky ferrata or otherwise known as
Chennai obvious our curries needless to
say the Indian influences in Malaysia
huge yeah it affects everyday life
crazy rich Asians took over the globe
this year now that you're on the other
side of the tornado what is the legacy
that comes with that and what does it
mean for asian-americans hopefully the
movies show that if we get people to
tell their own stories it can be not
only commercially viable but we end up
seeing really cool stories being told so
in this case you know we had a Asian
story written by someone from Singapore
he was writing a single post story and
we had a director and a cast that
embodied it you know this thing that you
would think is such a niche story which
is Asian people going back to Asia and
and meeting their family it's actually
quite universal so I hope that's the
legacy of the movie in American show
business well thanks for joining me
two hot pots in one sitting I've never
done that all to mention a barbecue and
a barbecue and if you are one of the
three people who haven't watched crazy
graduations you better do that [ __ ]
right now on The Daily Show on The Daily
Show and on Twitter and Instagram and
website they got a website he's on Yelp
leaving reviews let's leave him a review
he did a great job I will come and film
with you anytime
[Music]